- [Gary] Gary, how are you?
- Tom.
Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are you, brother?
- [Man] Alright, so we'll start
off with that first question.
Should people make
New Year's resolutions?
- People should make New Year's
resolutions if they're actually
watching this
video on January 1st.
If they're watching it on
December 23rd they should make
December 23rd resolutions.
Waiting miraculously to when the
calendar flips to start making
your life better is silly at
best and pisses me off at worst.
And so, whenever you're watching
this because it was on the
internet and thus that means
you could watch this on
June 17, 2017 make
a resolution every day
of your life 'cause you
only get one at-bat.
The reason people struggle with
having a New Year's resolution
and sticking to it is
because it was a tactic
to do a New Year's resolution.
Hence, why my
first answer was right
which is when you actually
decide to make a
change in your life,
whether about weight or job
or going out with somebody
or relationships, that's when
you actually pull it off.
It's religion, not tactics.
- [Man] Awesome, cool.
That's all we need.
- Great.
(group laughter)
Amazing. You got it.
(R&amp;B music)